exactamente andrés muy buenas noches
para ustedes los saludos desde el norte
de la ciudad de bogotá la capital
colombiana como usted lo decía pues esta
es la sede de campaña regional de bogotá
del candidato rodolfo hernández la gran
sede de su candidatura está en la ciudad
de bucaramanga capítal del departamento
de santander en la zona del nororiente
colombiano que es donde se ha reunido la
gran mayoría de los seguidores de
rodolfo hernández para celebrar este
paso a la segunda vuelta presidencial en
colombia que se han reunido como ustedes
ven algunos de los seguidores están
simplemente reunidos no podemos decir
que haya más de 100 personas acá pero
han venido espontáneamente para expresar
su apoyo a este candidato que claramente
pues rompe con la tradición colombiana
con el discurso completamente el cívico
simple y muy contundente hablando de
anticorrupción como su bandera de
campaña pero con un programa que todavía
muchas personas se preguntan cuáles son
los fundamentos de las propuestas que él
hace en su programa de trabajo habla de
diferentes puntos pero muchos se
preguntan cómo lo va a lograr hacer y
después ahora el candidato que pasa en
la segunda posición a disputarse esta
segunda vuelta presidencial en colombia